is the fifth Danette friend of the show
he's a Hall of Famer Reggie Aloysius
Miller jr. the third on hand for the
Lakers Clippers tonight he'll be on the
call on TNT alongside Kevin Harlan and
Allie LaForce and also Clippers warriors
this Thursday night also on TNT as we
make way for the great Reggie Miller
morning reg how are you in all my
problems during the summer right yeah
people always come up to me and say when
are you coming back on the Dan Patrick
show as being the fifth dammit I'm the
only one that gets to walk out music so
call it a comeback show better known as
the Dan Patrick show people how was your
summer
it was great yeah I'm more excited about
look I've been associated 18 years
professionally playing for Indiana I'm
going into my 15th year at Turner so
over 30 years in the NBA and this is the
first time I've actually I'm really
excited about this season this is it's
so up in the air with all the changes
and the duo's I'm excited for your door
all right the number one storyline in
the NBA this season regular season is
what well I think it will start in with
LeBron adding Anthony Davis that's the
big story line duos which duo is better
Paul George Klein lynyrd once Katie
comes back in Kyrie you know Stefan
D'Angelo the new making of that duo B
you know with clay possibly being out
the whole year are better but LA the
Battle of the Battle of LA is probably
the number one storylines
well and and then you got Westbrook and
harden as well as far as do I was
correct
if I just took out the team it was just
those two if I add a game of two-on-two
and I said Durant and Kyrie less Brook
harden Kauai and George and Anthony
Davis and LeBron now let me put in clay
I'll put in clay in step two because I'm
putting in an injured Kevin Durant by
the way it looks like a pretty good show
sounds like a pretty good show so if I
give two one two
who wins two on two out of those I would
probably go with LeBron and ad followed
by Kawhi I'm talking about healthy Kawhi
Paul George
probably tied with Kyrie and and KD
there's a lot of question marks the
soldier the the soldier injury to
peih-gee the achilles of of Katie so now
let's say everybody's healthy I'm still
going with LeBron and probably still go
with LeBron and eighty if is winning a
championship or bust for the Lakers if
the Lakers don't win a championship like
is the expectation level that high even
though the Clippers are the favorites if
the Lakers don't win a championship
finish that sentence
sure it's a disappointment but you can
make a disappointment for all the teams
I mean there's eight or nine teams that
legitimate you want it all but obviously
growing up here in LA
it's a Laker town and the Lakers are
known for championships not just you
know getting you know the best players
you have to win with the best players
and right now you have two of the top
five players in the game and LeBron and
Anthony Davis so the expectations in my
opinion are much higher for them because
not only do you have the two best two of
the best five players in the game you're
playing for an organization that is
known for winning championships along
with the Celtics so to me the
expectations are much higher for the
Lakers do you think that there's load
management with the Clippers
is there gonna be load management with
the Lakers load management with Houston
any of these other teams driving me
crazy - theodor and yes there will be I
just play the game just play see here's
the thing load management for us back in
the 90s is your team was good enough
you put teams away by the third quarter
you got to rest in the fourth
that was load management playing 30
minutes 25 minutes
that was load management not taking off
games so yes they'll be load management
for Paul George when he comes back for
Kawhi here's the problem with load
management because it worked in
Toronto's favorites last year with Kauai
only playing sweat 60-plus game yeah but
he plays the most minutes in the
playoffs and was paid off with the
championship so everyone's gonna say see
it works look at Kauai but I think
you're cheating the game you're cheating
the fans if you're healthy enough to
play
and if your team is good enough put the
opposing team away and rest
that's your load management is there
anything the Commissioner can do about
load management no absolutely nothing
because I could come up with he tweaked
his ankle and shoot around and he's
day-to-day there's no way to really
quantify an injury but if I let's say I
reduce the schedule to 70 games do you
think then players will still do load
management and play 55 or 60 games so no
matter what the number is they're still
going to be load management for some of
these players their pockets I know I'm
just I know gotta fill that building up
look they're on the right direction by
limiting the back-to-backs
starting the season earlier so hopefully
look play the greatest player that I
ever played against and in our game was
Michael Jordan go back his title run he
was playing 82 games and playoffs play
yeah but Mike may have load management
if he played now yes he probably yes
he probably what just drives me crazy if
you're good enough yeah I just think
you're cheating the game if you could
play play did you see what Jordan had to
say about Steph Curry did you really say
that okay let me play it for everybody
he was talking about he was asking his
ideal five is best starting five and I
included Scottie Pippen in there and and
then he gets to Steph Curry this is what
he had to say on The Today Show would
you keep the same four in a heartbeat
and I'm going into trenches I played
against and with all these guys I'm
going with who I know every single night
that responsibility go out there and
represent greatness every single night
so Steph Curry shouldn't be offended
when he watches I hope not he's still a
great player not a hall-of-famer yet
though you know okay Steph Curry a Hall
of Famer reg again what did I just say
about Michael the greatest player I ever
played against and of this generation by
far his competitive nature unmatched I
would tell everyone the greatest of all
time but in terms of recognizing Talent
absolutely not Steph Curry can stop
today and be a first-ballot
hall-of-famer Michael changed the game
he everyone wanted to be like Mike
because we all thought we could fly
right Steph has changed the game because
of his shooting he's changed the way
it's perceived the rules
he's an outlier so Steph doesn't have to
take another dribble again two-time MVP
and three-time champ right when I saw
that quote I thought like okay let me
think of some guys who are in the Hall
of Fame that Steve Nash a player VP if
I'm correct right yeah never sniffed the
finals right never sniffed the finals
first ballot hall-of-famer so you
tell me Steve Nash who deserves to be in
the Hall of Fame but Steph Curry right
now is not it Mike
I love you you are 100% dead wrong my
friend the Zion Williamson injury I'm
concerned more but that's maybe because
I've had all these knee surgeries that
you know at his size and the way he
plays I don't know if Wade is going to
continue to be an issue and if you know
this knee continues to be an issue and
maybe I'm an alarmist ear reg but I come
from a pretty good sample size of all
the knee surgeries I've had what do you
make of this injury and how serious do
you think it's going to be I don't think
the league has had this much buzz
probably since LeBron and heights behind
it and I for one was excited to see this
young man play in which we still will it
just it's going to take some time I'm
with you Theodore I'm an alarmist as
well and people and the pelicans can say
all they want is that they're not going
to monitor his weight the issue has
nothing to do with weight I'm here to
tell you she plays with a reckless
abandon which I like he plays with so
much force which I love but he's going
to have to monitor his weight he's going
to have to lose weight if he wants to
play that way and if he wants to play 10
plus 15 plus years and be a superstar
yeah he cannot have these weight issues
to me I believe he's 20 to 25 pounds and
I'm being generous here overweight and I
don't know if it's gonna get any better
after having surgery because he's gonna
be off his lathe he's not gonna be able
to really work out so to me they're
gonna have to monitor it going forward
but he's a little heavy Theodore he
really is yeah and I'm not you know I'm
not trying to dog this young man because
I want to see him ball out I think he's
a remarkable talent and he is exactly
what this game needs but they're going
to have to monitor that weight
and what eat well Barkley lost weight
when he got to the NBA and people try to
compare the two yeah and if you go back
to Philadelphia Charles Charles was a
ball even Phoenix girls he didn't have
the type of weight but also he didn't
have the explosiveness as I have but
Charles was Charlton starts becoming big
Charles till he got in the set of Turner
maybe towards the end of that Houston
you know but Charles would start putting
wait till he started to retire if he
wants to play with that fourth eye on
which he should quick jumper second
jumps rug being able to run the floor if
he wants longevity in this game he's
going to have to monitor it what did you
make of the whole China situation here
of the NBA going over there and playing
a couple of games and then heading home
I think it was a fiasco on both ends you
know look I understand girl more ways
you know freedom of speech and
expression that's kind of how we grew up
here in America and the NBA is making a
lot of money over there in China and
it's a double-edged sword
have you been to China I never have no
never yeah because they love their
basketball over there and I understand
why some of these marquee guys were
upset because they're losing out on some
money but there's people fighting for
human rights - yeah no no no I'm saying
it's a double-edged sword and is there I
don't think you really can there is no
real winner here but you know daryl
morey did what he did and LeBron said
what he said and we'll see how this you
know going forward you know what happens
to with like we said all you only got to
follow the money right kind of follow
the money yeah and there's a lot of
money going that's being had in China
and it's unfortunate
well you reveal your NBA
in ship pick next week I won't need 20
games to see everyone but as of now you
see my final four my final four in the
east
I have Milwaukee and Philadelphia
playing to one another with still was
Milwaukee the number one seed Philly the
number two seed with Philly winning the
East and I have Baker's clippers with
the Clippers having the number one seed
or the number two seed in the Western
Conference
I believe Denver is going to have the
number one seed but I have the Lakers
clippers in the Western Conference
Finals with the Clippers winning the
West and then after that I don't care
because the ATP takes over the final
[Laughter]
pick it out reg will be on the call the
best shooter in the building tonight
will be broadcasting the game Lakers
clippers that'll be at 10:30 Eastern
Kevin Harlan le laforce and reg and then
Thursday it'll be the Clippers and the
Warriors you won't be the best shooter
in the building that night real great to
have you back reg we'll talk to you next
week
you are the back for more Dan Patrick
show tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]